well sure if we go off trafalgar and
rasmussen
and democracy institute trump's winning
so we don't know what's going to happen
and that's why it's fair point the polls
are wrong simply because
all of the polls disagree with each
other my favorite thing about polling is
that when you look at the real clear
politics average it's like trump minus
two
trump minus twelve trump minus four
trump minus twenty and i'm like what is
this okay like none of these things like
that they're all random jibber blah blah
blah
what is the real politics average the
real clear politics average yeah what is
that they take a bunch of different
polls
from like the past several weeks and
then average out the total
approval two weeks ago one the seven
days ago
it's the best way to do it in my opinion
because they'll they'll put rasmussen up
against
say like um yougov or cbs or something
so you'll see rasmussen typically
leaning in favor of trump but rasmussen
was right
in there in their national polling uh
predictions for 2016.
wow they said hillary clinton was going
to win by you know two points or
whatever she did
everyone else was was was wrong by
another point or so
so when rasmussen right now is saying
that trump's support uh approval from
the black voters at 46
the argument is they were right last
time the other thing is emerson
in earlier this year saw the same thing
they said trump's approval among black
voters at 30 percent
if that's true trump cannot lose period
period wow it's a long-standing uh trope
i guess
that if a republican ever gets 20 of the
black vote the democrats will never win
again
that's fascinating i was unfamiliar so
whether or not trump actually gets that
yeah we'll see
we just we actually actually i will no
longer
vote we got this story good do it gotta
do it oh yeah the story
50 cent oh donald trump oh
boy now they're saying he's back they're
saying he's backtracking i don't think
he backtracked i don't i don't think i
don't think so who was that lady who was
on
who's like i need to remind him he's
black chelsea chelsea
wait that wasn't the only thing she said
oh no she not only agreed to i don't
wanna i'm taking my headphones i don't
wanna hear it
she not only a great now you can hear me
listen listen she not only agreed to pay
his tax bill
if he reconsiders his support for trump
which i'm pretty sure is illegal
blackmail
she also agreed to sleep with him
well i'm sorry i'm sorry she said she
said she said
horrible go another round that's what
she said yeah terrible
i'm pretty sure that's illegal that's
disgusting anyway
and of course i mean i'm sure they
played off as i'm sure she's like doing
a bit but that's still
horrible
like a authoritarian but at some point
you gotta lock somebody up yeah i mean i
don't know if i'd
i think i i don't know if i i mean i
think she was joking but still a
horrible thing isn't it well look what
do you think
okay joking doesn't matter 50 said 62
tax under joe biden f that vote trump
i don't care if trump doesn't like black
people i don't want to be 20 cent
yeah that's hilarious and then he's
correct and then chelsea handler was
like you know she did all these things
then 50 cent uh posted again f donald
trump i never liked him anyway
i'm not i don't i don't think that's a
backtrack i don't think he liked
i don't think he likes trump in the
first place he said i don't care if
trump doesn't like black people
his 50 cent doesn't want to pay all
those taxes of course is this the first
time
i still love it is this the first
candidate to ever run on raising
people's taxes
i heard that i don't know if that's true
though oh man like a president being
like
read my lips i'm going to tax people
many new taxes yeah yeah if you're like
me or your taxes are going to go up yeah
he's like saying he would raise our
taxes which is great
you know people voters love hearing that
i love how this doesn't realize that's
one of those things you're supposed to
lie about
like that's
you know i love how the media and
twitter have been lying for him yeah
it's the funniest thing oh and then i
hear people say it to me and i'm like
let's sit sit down my child like they're
like
joe biden's not raising taxes on people
you're so dumb he's only gonna raise
taxes on people who make more than four
hundred thousand dollars a year guy
you're so dumb
um i have a question my friend is
removing a tax cut
raising people's taxes yes what do you
mean well so joe biden said he's going
to repeal trump's tax cuts on day one
does that mean that people's taxes will
go up yes so joe biden is going to take
an action that results in your taxes
going up yes so joe biden is going to
raise your taxes
no he's only raising taxes oh he's going
to raise taxes on everybody dude
so what's funny is with the trump tax
cuts
as typically happens with the the trump
tax cuts we actually saw an increase in
revenue
but they say that there's a decrease in
revenue because they spent more than the
increase was after we pulled it in
which is a ridiculous way to argue uh
that position that's the strongest yeah
yeah so tax cuts are good for the
country ladies and gentlemen and good
for individual people and i'm a
middle-class person you know like i
i um i'm like pretty firmly in the
middle class making an average living
and the trump tax cuts saved me a good
amount of money on my taxes i'm gonna
i'm gonna
i'm gonna let you all in a big secret do
it did you know that cutting taxes can
actually
increase tax revenue no yeah it's
jurisdiction it does yeah it does well
every single time
i mean the trump tax cuts did increase
revenue but what happened was
they spent the surplus right so that
yeah and so they used that to argue that
we actually have less money than we did
before therefore his tax cuts decreased
our revenue
but revenue is the incoming money minus
the outgoing money that isn't just the
revenue is just the incoming money how
can they say that the expenditures lower
the revenue
because i think that they might have
they spent more than they had so yeah
well they lying but also they spent more
than they had
so they were under budget i think so
then they're saying oh well that means
revenue
but they still actually like raw revenue
actually did increase the amount that
they pulled in
yeah the government pulled in here's
what's higher here here's what happens
uh i probably told the story on this uh
on the show before but
there was a friend of mine this is maybe
like 15 16 years ago a friend of mine
her dad was a contractor apparently
there was like
a home depot or something in cook county
chicago
and they shut down and then moved like
five or six miles away into dupage
county and reopened
and i like we were talking about it he
said this is a really good example of
raising taxes not working because when
they raised the sales tax in cook county
by like point zero two percent
or some really small number the people
who are like the the contractors say i
go to home depot i order my wood
point two percent over the year averages
out i'm gonna lose twenty thousand
dollars
i will drive an extra thirty miles for
my orders and for my deliveries if it
means i'm saving 20 grand
so the home depot was like we're losing
business because of this we're going to
reopen a few miles down the road
and we're going to save our business so
what ends up happening is cook county
lost all tax revenue trying to get a
little bit more
yep because jurisdictions are competing
with each other yes
so so long as we don't have like a
nationwide uniform sales tax
the competition will exist and then
someone in cook county will be like i'm
going to go buy my expensive electronics
and dupage whether
the sales tax is lower and i'm going to
save myself 20 bucks yes it's worth
driving a few extra miles you know why
because business people can still do
math even though politicians can
exactly that's the trick there is
superpower you can only
online oh well no i just wanted to bring
the receipts on what i was saying
earlier
according to the congressional budget
office data in the 2019 fiscal year
federal revenues increased by four
percent
but spending increased by eight percent
right
so they said the deficit spiked
therefore trump's tax cuts didn't work
no his tax cuts did work the american
people got more money in their own
pockets and it was also better for the
government because they actually made
more revenue
or pulled in more revenue but they can't
get money they can't take money in
without spending more than they took in
because they have no self-control
and so the deficit did increase but
that's not a problem with the tax cuts
that's a problem with our spending
problem now
here's how it works federally with
federal tax cuts because there's no
external jurisdiction
it's simple if i give a dollar to
sheamus
he's got to pay 20 cents to the
government he now has 80 cents
he then uses 80 cents to buy a widget
from you
you got to pay 16 cents on your 80 cents
so
the more money you guys have the more
opportunity for trade so
more tidbits keep getting stripped away
and given to the government the simple
way to put it is
if you tax at 30 percent then sheamus
only has 70 cents he can't afford your
80 cent widget anymore he doesn't buy it
they don't get any tax revenue after the
first exchange until later on so it can
slow down or stagnate the market
resulting in less revenue making its way
to the government for
expenses exactly or yeah yeah or my
business grows we're actually making
much more
i hire more people now there's more
payroll taxes being paid to the
government
i'm sure there are economists listening
right now screaming about all the little
things
i know i know i know but um i know that
i mean the healthier the economy if you
have a healthy enough economy even if
tax rates are lower revenue is higher
because everyone is earning more and so
even though they're giving a lower
percentage of their income to the
government
it's actually uh a a larger amount
i got to say i love how academic we
brought this conversation considering we
started with 50 cents saying f trump and
chelsea handler being like
well hook it up baby he doesn't want to
be 20 cent and i get it well so sorry so
i'm looping it back because of a little
pump let's do it what happened with a
little pump
no i now 50 cent wasn't quite able to
sway me but
i want to hear what little pump had to
say lil pump posted an instagram photo
of him shaking hands without
trump what is this i don't know if it's
real is it is a real photo
i don't know here's the thing little
pump is one thing if little yachty
endorses donald trump then there's no
way that he's losing lil pump made a
video where he was like
something like i think i don't know
exactly what he said i thought he said
something like f joe biden no way i'm
paying another 30 something percent in
taxes
trump 2020. this this matters to all of
these artists because cardi b
did something similar she's like i'm
looking at my taxes this is insanity how
are y'all paying this much in taxes
um she was talking about how um bernie
is how her guy
i don't understand it i just went from
taxes being crazy
because everyone wants the government to
pay for everything while still not
having to pay more in taxes
dude it's really it's really simple it's
like listen all of us are sitting right
here yeah
i i would like to vote to take sheamus's
tie
all in favor yep you're not voting this
time thank you
thank you thank you and it is yours we
did it last time
i was tricked twice no longer i'm going
to vote in favor of sheamus gets it
keep us die can we get no i'm not voting
for that either what are you doing
i'm staging a protest okay hold on stop
stop evil happens when good men failed
unfortunately you
you don't like that i would say it's a
solution i have a solution
i would say i have a solution i vote in
favor of taking ian's shirt
oh okay whatever all in fact
i remembered i remember
well i want it back so uh hey how do you
guys feel about
repealing or paring down um income tax
oh yeah abolish the income tax you think
you think abolished income tax yeah
no i mean like that's not something we
could do today but eventually i
i mean again theoretically i'm okay with
some level of taxation because
there are certain government services
that need to be paid for but
historically we mostly paid for that
with tariffs or
god forbid sales taxes but it's not as
if an income tax is an absolute
necessity for running a government and
you essentially find people i mean you
actually alter people's time preference
based on whether or not
they have the assurance that they'll be
able to keep the money that they're
working for so you can make the economy
and i would argue do make the economy
less productive just by having an income
tax
okay okay but but haven't the people of
earth
already proven they lack the cognitive
ability of self-management therefore we
must tax 100 of their income
and dictate on their behalf with the ai
controlling all of their actions
yeah of course how can i forget no if we
just hook everyone's brain into a
computer let mark zuckerberg run this
whole thing
jack dorsey's already running it like
this twitter
twitter is the interface for the
simulation could you imagine if like
actually this the simulation i
understand we're trying to make the
simulation
more fair for everyone and the only way
to do that is if conservatives aren't
allowed to speak
so could you so so we have this image of
jack dorsey as this like hippie guy with
a beard who's talking really slow
but i'm just i'm loving the idea that
like after
you know so i sat down with him we
talked we talked for a little bit before
the rogan podcast
we talked a little bit afterwards and he
very much you know it's very similar
i'm just imagining as soon as he got in
the car he like
the beer the beer don't know the beard's
fake he pulls it off and he's like
now back to twitter to take over the
world
and he's got like a freaky fake movie
accent and like freaking knew it
i imagine twitter headquarters inside
everything's like all of the walls are
black metal paneling with red lights
everywhere
and they all wear these like uniforms
and it's just jack saying like
manipulating people choosing political
opinions picking the winners and losers
what stories are allowed what aren't
what if what if what if you mentioned
jack dorsey is already controlling
everything yeah he is
what if it's literally him i kind of
love twitter
what's wrong with you i just i never
you're sick humans i got my account in
2008
when i was doing youtube a bunch of us
youtubers were like twitter hey
the next new big thing i was like i just
got facebook i don't want to get a third
thing that's
right exactly same as facebook that's
the exact same if i'm going to do a text
message to my followers
i'll use facebook don't bother me i'll
do a group chat
i just recently started using twitter
like a couple months ago and i love it i
like it i like that you can you know the
best
but i i feel like i i i've learned to
love it you know why i do
because you're a masochist you guys
that's called stockholm no no no no no
you like twitter no
because you're identifying with your
captor no actually i started paying a
bit more
attention to michael mallis's twitter oh
she's all right that's fair okay
all right he rules and i've learned from
him because he is the king
when he when he's literally the king of
twitter when he responds to donald trump
with
we don't deserve to deserve him i'm like
that's it he's figured it out
so now i don't capitalize letters i just
tweet no no you don't put commas you
just right
i just i'm just i just stopped caring
completely and i want them like
i figured there's nothing you can tweet
without someone's like someone's head
exploding
so i'm like i'll just just don't care i
just
like i tweeted i tweeted it'll be really
funny if joe biden wins because actually
it'll be kamala
like i just don't i just whatever i just
thought of something and now i tweeted
basically like my shower thoughts
he does yeah and then he writes
in water so toilet thoughts yeah so when
you're getting bombarded with all this
water you're getting the information of
ages past
possibly seeping into your dna yeah we
don't live
we don't live in breath of the wild
where the liquid
information lands like if that's true
then jack dorsey is doing a crazy job
running this simulation dude yeah that's
amazing i have thought about it i know
why it is it's because we're isolated
from tech that's all it is we're not
allowed to talk oh so we have these
weird thoughts
in the shower yeah people like shower
thoughts all the time shower thoughts
didn't originate
look i'm sitting there at my computer
all day and i'm like be reading the news
and i'll just like think of something
and just tweet it
yeah and i don't capitalize letters
anymore no he gave up
you know why because it used to be like
i remember because he doesn't like
capitalism i made it through i made a
joke horrible
no you guys are gonna love this i made a
joke something about uh
they said greta turnberg endorses joe
biden and i thought my tweet was very
clearly meant to
be like sarcastic or satirical i said
i know i think it was i think most
people got it but some people didn't i
said
uh this is collusion of the highest
order we must not allow sweden
you know to get away with something like
that and i'm like
greta tunberg saying she likes joe biden
is clearly not yeah but i got a bunch of
leftists all like high-fiving each other
and laughing being like tim's so dumb oh
he really thinks she's colluding sweden
oh he's so stupid
and i'm like i'm i'm into it i'm like
it's hilarious
yeah i just you go for it yeah i've
tweeted i don't know i i stopped even
trying to explain jokes because it's not
smart enough to edit it i have a really
similar story uh i tweeted
that on the top of twitter i tweeted
twitter's been utterly destructive for
society and jack refuses to shut it down
why
because he's made upward of fifteen
thousand dollars running it like it's a
joke just like a vast
underestimation and then i was like and
i was like actually i think it might
even be twice that like more than twice
that
and there were one or two people who
commented like i think it's more than
fifteen thousand dollars
that's how i learned to love it yeah
because i remember i made a joke a year
or so ago
and everyone was like you're so dumb and
i was like guys i'm joking
no no you can't do anything it's like
joshing around no it's like
you you put out a tweet and people can't
tell to joke because sometimes these
things don't read through
there's no point trying to explain it no
just roll with it just get it go into it
so my response to people then was like i
just i just went with it i was like it's
collusion uh like how dick
and then i started accusing uh uh biden
of colluding with kazakhstan
because borax yeah because of borat and
people were like
these like these people they're just
like he's doing it again
he's so dumb and i'm like i'm i'm into
this i'm just getting really
it's a great i mean it's it's a good
tactic in some ways because
you make some certain number of your
opponents look very stupid
when they take the bait that's not it
i'm if i have a joke i'll make a joke no
no i'm not saying that that's the reason
you're doing it but that is like an
added benefit
like wow these people actually genuinely
believe this i think most of them
probably know it's a joke
but my favorite is when something is
obviously joke because i've seen this
happen to other public figures where
they'll say something ridiculous
intentionally and people will go whoa
you really believe that
and then when they they make it clear
that they were joking the response is
like
oh he's playing it off as a joke now did
you see something he meant
that coyote thing yes when donald trump
was like
the kids are being brought over by the
coyotes do we need a wall with fake
tunnels painted at it
and then you get all these blue checks
i'm just imagining they're all sitting
around high-fiving each other
they're like smart it's the craziest
thing i was talking to this guy i know
and i was like dude
he's like a leftist and i said you got
to realize man all of these people
you understand they're dumb right but
they think they're smart
so they're like midwifes michael mouse
about this yeah 100
midwifes they think they're smart and
they're like
trump's so dumb he thinks dogs are
carrying babies
what a [ __ ] it's like do you have
google the coyotes
dogs but it's not the phone no no the
crazy thing i saw that i saw someone
saying dogs
it's not the first time that's happened
in 2018
vox.com had to write a whole article
because their audience is too
stupid to know what a coyote is so they
were like no
trump didn't mean dogs but because they
were trying to defend their audience
they're like but maybe he kind of did
no he never meant canines or whatever
what's what's the what's the latin
family lupus
and that's wolf and i'm too embarrassed
to ask tim
but
uh um child trafficking okay okay
no no a coyote is a brown creature that
walks on two legs and purchases
explosives from the acme corporation
donald trump is stupid he thought that
they were bringing babies over
can you believe that that trump thought
while e coyote was
like chasing the road runner with babies
he's so dangerous kaufman is one of my
idols we need to fit we need a bunch of
sticks of dynamite to stop because
we need to we need to get me a giant
helmet and put me in a cannon
to launch me at the coyote my problem
with with satire
is that if you're someone in the news or
that's like people trust
if you do satire i am afraid that it
draws your entire body of work into
question
but you're funny as hell ah and i think
uh there's something to humor like if
you weren't funny
that you'd be one side i'm willing i'm
willing to bet many of my jokes on
twitter are not
funny i don't care twitter is my place
for shower thoughts i'm not a comedian
but i do commentary so if i make
commentary that's potentially humorous
or whatever i'm not i'm doing commentary
if i it so a lot of people have fallen
into this
so you've got a lot of actual
journalists whose job is to be a
journalist but they go on twitter and
they post activism and snarky humor all
day
now i understand they shouldn't be doing
that i do political commentary analysis
and i make jokes in my analysis i would
say it's a small percentage
of very very small where there's like
sometimes people telling me like i
watched your videos really funny and i'm
like i'm not doing a bit like i don't
have jokes i don't script anything i
just
give my like take on things and
sometimes i'll say something
that's same thing with twitter sometimes
i'll just be like here's a point and
like i'm being sarcastic
people yeah i get like that when i would
see like uh news anchors and movies
and i'm like wait are they a news anchor
are they an actor
oh yeah i wonder if they're like
anderson cooper like a c thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you